معكم هذه الصور المباشره من منطقه كهرمان
مرعش لعمال انقاذ وهم يتواجدون يتواجدون
داخل احد المباني وكما يبدو وكانها نقاشات
تدور بين هذه الفرق حول كيفيه اتمام عمليه
الانقاذ والبحث والانتشار ايضا في هذا
المبنى الذي انهار ايضا بسبب الزلزال
الكبير الذي ضرب تركيا يوم الاثنين الماضي
ضربت طبعا جنوب تركيا وشمال غرب سوريا
بشده بلغت سبع درجات الفاصله ثمانيه درجات
الحاصيه الاجماليه مشاهديا نذكر بها لعد
القتلى حتى الان في البلدين تجاوزت خمسه
وثلاثين الف قتيل وفق حصيله جديده غير
نهائيه كما ان منظمه الصحه العالميه اكدت
ان 26 مليون شخص قد تاثروا بهذا الزلزال
في كل من سوريا وتركيا بينما قدرت الامم
المتحده ان عدد القتلى سيتجاوز 40 الفا
واكدت ان مرحله الانقاذ في تركيا اقتربت
ايضا من نشاهد ايضا هذا الخبر العاجل
النقلا عن مرصد الزلازل التركيه يتحدث عن
تسجيل ثلاث هزات اعتداديه في كهرمان
المرعى الشماسه امس اذا مرصد الزلازل
التركيه يتحدث عن تسجيل ثلاث هزات
ارتداديه في منطقه كهرمان مرعش التي نتابع
صورها الان منذ يوم امس
مساله الهدف من المشاكل ايضا التي يعاني
منها عمال انقاذ والتي تهدد ايضا هذه
الجهود وتتسبب احيانا ايضا في سقوط
المباني المتصدعه
ما يشكل خطا ايضا على عمال الانقاذ وعلى
من هم من الناجين تحت هذا الركام اذا
مشاهدينا ما زلنا معكم في متابعه لهذه
الصور المباشره من منطقه كهرباء مرعشلي
عمال الانقاذ وهم يتواجدون داخل احد
المباني
مشاهدينا بعد نحو عام من بدء الحرب في
اوكرانيا اتفقت روسيا واوكرانيا اخيرا على
قضيه واحده وهي ضروره اغاثه المتضررين من
الزلزال المدمره الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا
حيث اعلنت روسيا ارسال ثلاث طائرات تحتوي
على مساعدات انسانيه منها 500 خيمه وتسعه
الاف حقيبه نوم وحصائر عازيه للحراره
وتسعه عشر طنا من المنتجات الغذائيه من
جهتها قالت دائره الطوارئ الحكوميه
الاوكرانيه يوم الاحد قالت انه ممثلها
وعمار الانقاذ الاوكرانيين التقوا
بمسؤولين من اداره الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه افاد للتعاون بين رجال انقاذ
الاوكرانيين والاتراك